ATISSA BANUAZIZI:
In 8.13, students
have to present over
and over and over
again throughout the
course of the semester.
And we think that this iterative
process is really important.
We start out giving them some
instruction at the beginning
of the semester.
But often, they still
don't feel wholly
comfortable with
what they're doing
the first time they present.
And so once they've presented,
they get videotaped.
And then we meet with
them to discuss the video,
to discuss the slides,
to see what worked
and what didn't work.
And those one-on-one conferences
that we have with them,
they're reinforcing the core
concepts in the instruction
but in a way that's really
directly linked to the work
that they've already done, the
work that they're continuing
to do, and to challenges that
they've already experienced
so they can really
understand the significance
of these strategies.
And so by the time
we have them revise
one of these presentations
that they present
in the public oral, which
is to their entire class
and, often, to people
outside the class--
they might be other faculty;
they might be friends
of the class of the students--
they're already fairly
experienced communicators.
And they have a pretty good idea
of what's effective and what
isn't.
A lot of classes
at the Institute
do a terrific job
of exposing students
to many, many genres
of communication.
What I think is unusual
about this class
is sort of how
deeply they're asked
to delve into a couple
of very specific genres.